In 2008, my next guest
became an internet sensation
and Mad TV cast member thanks
to her viral Nail Salon routine.
Since then, she's appeared
on shows like Superstore,
Ugly Betty as well as Curb Your Enthusiasm
and released 4 one hour specials already.
On August 20, you can see her hosting,
The Art of Comedy special which was shot
at the HA Festival in San Antonio.
Please welcome Anjelah Johnson.
Anjelah thank you for being here.
Thank you for having me.
That was a mouthful sorry to
give you every credit possible.
All of it. You text me word by word once.
How are you and your husband
handling the quarantine,
whole lockdown?
You know, we're actually
having a great time
which sometimes I try
not to tell everybody
how much fun we're having
because I know there's
a lot happening in the world so I like
to be like "Ah, hate it."
but really I love it so much.
I'm a homebody, love to be home
and we're getting creative.
Like we all have some celebrated birthdays
in quarantine so far.
My husband's birthday is July.
So we did Christmas in July
because he loves Christmas.
We decorated, we put the Christmas tree
out all the decorations everywhere.
And we did Christmas in July for like.
a good three weeks almost the whole month.
I feel like you could almost get away
with it in the lockdown at a point
where every day feels the same.
I couldn't tell you
what the date is today.
I feel like if I just
saw Christmas decorations
at the background, I guess
it's as good as Christmas now.
Yeah.
They're probably right.
They're probably right, dang it.
Yeah, I miss that too.
That's why we're drinking
in the middle of the afternoon.
Cheers of drinking that ginger max.
What do you got over there?
Cheers, it seems we have the same cup.
Look at this.
Yes.
I watched it last night,
The Art of Comedy,
which is a cool way to set up comedy.
Thanks for watching it.
Yeah, and you know how it used to be
and I don't know maybe you
could tell me move around
but it looks like you're
having a lot of fun.
What was your favorite part
about shooting the special?
My favorite part about
shooting this special
with other comics is that
there was other comics there
because I'm used to being
on the road by myself.
It's me, my opener, my
road manager, and that's it
and then we're on the road.
And then when we come home, most comics
will like go hit up the Comedy Store,
the improv, laugh factory, whatever.
A lot of times, I just want to be home
because like I said, I'm
a homebody, I like that.
So I'll do like dinner with
my friends or just stay home
and watch Law & Order, SVU in
my own bed or my own couch,
and then pack and get
back on the road again.
So a lot of times I'm
just with three people,
my road manager and my
opener and that's it.
So one of my favorite
parts was the camaraderie
with the other comics and being backstage
and then hanging out
after having drinks after
and like that whole thing.
That was probably my favorite part,
was hanging out with everybody.
I know what you mean because when you get
to your success level, you
almost get a little isolated
from when you start.
When you're in the clubs
with everyone every night
or you're just grinding out
trying to get sets anywhere.
When you get to your level,
it's like now you're just on the road.
Yeah.
But then, show's over,
you have really no one
to decompress with.
And comics talk away that is,
I know you can't be that
mean to any other people
like you can be mean to
comics there's a special way.
It's a nice language.
Yeah, we have a special way.
This special was a debut for one
of my friends, Pedro Selena.
So I started out doing open mics with.
No way how cool!
Yeah, just like the worst rooms that
we performed at, a room
that was a juice bar,
and the blender would start immediately.
No.
Which is very exciting.
It was cool to see him
get his first TV set.
Yeah.
Do you remember your first set?
'Cause it's a different experience
than just doing at a club.
My first TV set was Premium Blend
on Comedy Central years ago.
And it was a bunch of comics and then
they would have like a
headliner hosting it.
Jeff Dunham was my host.
The puppet god. Yeah.
Yes.
And then on my episode was also a comic,
she ended up falling off
you may not have heard
of her, Amy Schumer.
Amy Schumer, does she run
crawfish room in deep San Diego?
She used to, yeah.
She used to do that.
I think she worked at
Massage Envy now I donna.
Yeah, that's huge.
That's a huge first taping.
Yeah.
And like I was joking
saying like our careers went
at different paces, but
you know what, it's fine.
We're all doing our
own journey here, okay?
One thing that stood out to me
that I really appreciated it,
is your hosting this thing.
Not only did you get
everyone's name right, crucial,
but you gave really
nice intros to everyone.
We always feel like you know
the comic before they get up
so you don't have to do that extra step
of digging yourself out back.
Here's who I am.
That I really appreciated
it, the intros you gave.
So thank you for doing that.
And also, I'm sure you've gotten
bad intros in your career.
I mean, the worst pros.
I've witnessed people
get some real bad ones
where it's like super cringe worthy.
Yeah,
One time I was at the
improv and, you know,
it's one of those nights
where just whoever goes up,
and somebody's hosting it, and the guy
that was going up next,
I forget who it was.
But he was pretty famous,
like, more famous for acting
than stand up, I remember
but it's like you've seen him
in like so many different
movies type of guy.
And whoever was hosting forgot his name.
So he does that whole thing where he goes,
"This next comic, he
needs no introduction."
I mean, you've seen him everywhere.
He doesn't even need an
intro, just come on out here."
And then it's like,
all of us are like, "Oh, he
totally forgot his name."
Clearly vamping this
person, what a human being?
What a guy that says that just a guy,
he's also you know a girl in a way.
Everyone is everyone and
what is the universe even?
Oh, you suck when it comes to you.
Also that type of intro
like, you don't need intro,
like it better be the
biggest person in the world.
Sure, and you don't say
he doesn't need an intro,
please welcome Dave
Chappelle, then it's like,
"Oh, you forgot his bio then."
Right.
The worst for me is corporate gigs.
Okay, why?
This is why.
Because here you are sitting
in this like conference room
of what, tech company
blah, blah, blah, right?
And so they're not used to
introducing entertainers.
That's not what they do.
They just have like, you
know, Susan, from HR,
who's gonna read your bio, you know,
and we're like, at the club, we know like,
the last thing you hear
is the comics name,
and then they come up, right.
And usually at a corporate gig,
it's something like "And this performer,
we're happy to bring up Anjelah Johnson."
And then I start walking out and they go,
she has been and then they
name everything I've ever done
from the Snickers commercial
when I was 23 to like
what I did yesterday and then after like,
a good 10-minute intro then
they're like, come on, now.
So you're at this point already
on the stage like,
"Well, I heard my name."
And that's when we know
to go up and you have
to hear whatever Wikipedia
thing they downloaded
Sure, Sure, Sure.
I remember I got brought
up once for like in
from the contract is like my
name first and I'm already
on stage just like
hunched over in the dark.
And it was like,
"From the controversial
Burger King commercial,
here he is."
And I was like okay, well, I
do anything with the burgers
is like a different reason.
Like there is a controversial
Burger King commercial,
wait a minute.
I guess it's set off
everyone's like home assistant,
Alexa or Siri or something.
Oh, I didn't know that.
Yeah, was like on purpose.
And for some reason that
made it into the stage intro
and that was, it is a college campus,
So it's like, wait controversy?
What did he do?
Yeah.
Who did he sleep with?
He slept with one of the burgers
which I wouldn't put it past men.
Yeah.
In this special, The Art of Comedy,
some of the comics perform at a riverboat,
which is gonna pitch it's like hell gig
'cause it's like a out
tour on a boat tourists.
But I don't know, the longer
I don't perform on stage,
I was very watching it because I'm like,
"I think I could do that gig now?"
I was the cool call out in this special.
He doesn't know
(faintly speaking)
it makes an appearance.
Yeah.
And especially to introduce.
It was cool to be a part of
something with her like this.
And honestly to acknowledge
like our culture.
You know what I mean, like to acknowledge
that there are funny Latino people,
funny like we're really talented
and let's highlight some of us
like that was an honor to do
because a lot of time, I
mean, like, we're making fun,
like diversity matters, though.
And so
Yeah.
That's why I was really super honored
to be a part of this
special and hosting it.
Because I want to see our stories told
and you know, like, we deserve that.
They're great stories.
Yeah, it's a really cool
way that HBO Max framed it
in that it's The Art of Comedy.
And it's not billed as these shows,
we get to feature these people that are
just have interesting points of views.
And kind of the fact that
they're Latin or Spanish,
has really nothing to do with
just that they're good at stand up.
Because a lot of times when
you first start your career,
it's like, well, we need a separate night
for all the Latin people.
It's EC Saturdays.
I did Refried Fridays for many years.
Nothing feels better than getting a check
that says Refried Fridays on it.
Just from my name alone,
it doesn't seem like
just a bland white guy name,
I would get put on Chocolate Sundays.
Really?
Urban show, yeah.
Oh. Yeah.
Ah, okay, do a bum name alone.
I think I did it like once
or twice Chocolate Sundays?
Angela, this was so
much fun talking to you.
Thank you so much for doing the show.
You're so funny and it's
really special I got
to be on this with you.
So thank you for having me.
Art of comedy special, cheers.
Cheers.